what's up elimination it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves I
my sincere hope is that if you see in
you what I see in you you'll be able to
change the planet so to help you on your
journey today I'm going to talk about
seven ways to make money as a teenager
[Music]
so I know I have a lot of young people
watch my youtube channel I love it I
wish YouTube was around when I was a
teenager trying to get started as an
entrepreneur and I wanted to make this
video today to kind of share how you can
get started how you can make money as a
teenager and 13 some real business
success and some results to achieve your
goal and not have to go get that typical
corporate job that you may not want to
do so today I'm going to share some of
the things that I actually did when I
was getting started as a teenage
entrepreneur but also some of the things
that I would do if I was starting again
now so I'm 37 right now if I was
starting up again what I would do today
[Music]
tip number one is understand where you
can bring value so the most important
business rule that you need to
understand is where you can bring value
to people is where you're going to make
money the more value you can bring to
somebody the more money you're going to
make it's it's the most important rule
about money so I'll be thinking about
where can I bring value to the people
around me to companies that I know the
people that I know what major problems
have I solved for myself that may be
valuable for other people out there as
well and I'd be looking for
opportunities where use is an advantage
because in some industries youth is a
negative you don't have the experience
but in some industries youth is an
advantage this did not exist 20 years
ago even when I was getting started ten
years ago wait how old 19 my first
company was 19 so almost 10 no almost 20
years getting old and getting old guys
37 so 19 20 years ago pretty much youth
was still seen as a negative like you
don't know what you're talking about you
have no experience now it's starting to
change in a lot of different industries
where youth is a benefit and if you can
solve a problem for yourself and bring
value to somebody else
then that's a quick path we will make
some money so understand the value that
you can bring to people
[Music]
since number two would start an online
business this is what I did when I was
at the very beginning my first company
again 19 years old I was actually really
concerned about selling the people
selling face to face selling over the
phone my voice sounded really young I
was telling the people who had PhDs who
are three times my age and on one side
it was a limiting belief you know all
they really cared about was that I could
provide them with some value back to
point number one but starting the online
business allowed me to do something that
I was good at right we understood
websites we understood how to sell
online it was something that people who
were older and think about this is 20
years ago to write things the idea of
having a website is not anything
revolutionary right now
but starting an online business in a
field where you can bring more expertise
and people who are three times your age
four times your age maybe it's something
that you can do as a young person to
bring a lot of value so I started online
with the website we started selling
internationally we started selling to
companies again around the world
internationally and so I would encourage
you to look at online opportunities that
fit your skill set again where you can
bring value so not just typical fill out
a survey and make some money or do some
boring data entry job right if you're
looking at what are you great at and
then how can you bring that service
online number three I would look at
hustle versus experience in some
businesses you need to do a lot of
hustle to stay on top of the game to
really understand how things are working
and in some businesses you need to have
a lot of experience to understand how it
has historically worked so you get a
sense of your success in that field and
so you're going to have a hard time
competing in the businesses and
industries where experience really
really really matters so if you want to
be a lawyer you know you kind of have to
understand the whole legal system if you
want to be a really great leader you
have to understand all the leadership
training have gone through actually
leading people before if you want to be
a great speaker you have to put in the
reps you have to do a lot of work to be
great at speaking it's something you
can't do it it's totally achievable you
know if you have a big goal and you are
working on it every single day you can
pass people who are more experienced
than you
so harder wrote the climb if you want to
get into an industry where experience
really matters versus ones where hustle
really matters so some example the first
thing I did when I sold my first
business was I went to go work with a
venture capital company I was curious
about the industry to have all the
connections in the industry takes time
to build up so what I did was I
connected with people who already had
those connections and I offered to come
in and hustle with them so my role was
to I wanted to learn the venture
capitalists I want to learn from these
guys and my role is to go out and drum
up a new business and so was talking to
new potential entrepreneurs who wanted
to raise capital who needed to grow and
to expand and then I relied on my you
know four partners there to be able to
provide the credentials experience the
connections and knowledge expertise all
the things that had to do with running a
business that they can give the advice
where my role is the hustle role so your
advantage as a young person is you can
hustle you could out help so you can
outwork a lot of people who are older
who may have other responsibilities who
may just not care as much about it I
look at YouTube as a great example one
it's newer medium so a lot of a lot of
the older people aren't even on YouTube
a lot of the great speakers of the world
are barely on YouTube that gives
opportunities for people who are not as
great at speaking right I'm not as great
at speaking as a lot of people who come
before me but because they're not on
YouTube or not nearly as much I can win
right and so the same thing for you guys
YouTube people complain about YouTube's
algorithm update changing all the time
that's great for you all the social
media networks with their algorithms
changing all the time it really promotes
somebody who loves the hustle versus
somebody who has experience so what
worked on YouTube five years ago doesn't
work as well as it does right now right
the idea of having consistent content
and looking at watch time versus what
YouTube cared about before makes a
difference and every time there's a new
update all you hear by are people
complaining
I can't believe Facebook did this I
can't believe YouTube that this I can't
believe Google did this and they
complain and they complain and they
complain because all the experience that
they gained is now useless or at least
has been diminished it's not as helpful
to them anymore
where the value is in the hustle to
figure out the new thing
I look at it in the eSports world as
well where when when riot introduces a
new patch for League of Legends we're
going niche now in eSports but I love
League of Legends there's always changes
that happen in the game and the teams
that win are the ones that adapt to the
changes fastest you have to constantly
be adapting to the changes that are
happening and if you just rely on your
experience and you're going to fall
apart now the way that League of Legends
was played last year is different than
it's played right now and that applies
to some industry is more rapidly than
other industries so if you want to be
the next great personal development
coach you can do it it's just a ton of
work and the guys like Tony Robbins are
ahead of you so it's going to be hard to
replace him or all the other people
because they have tons of experience
behind them but in other industries
where the Hustle is more important in
the experience you can get to number one
really really quickly tip number four is
go all in on your strengths what you
want to do is focus on the thing that
you are great at what do you love doing
how do you love spending your time and
try to provide value in that specific
niche as much as possible so for example
me if I was starting all over again if
I'm if I'm a teenager I'm in high school
or I'm just starting University and I'm
trying to figure out what business do I
want to go into I would look at online
marketing because I love online
marketing I would want to tell you guys
to get into online mark and you've got
to find the thing like get it into
online market because I tell you to is
the stupidest reason ever you want to go
into the thing that you have a passion
for that you're consuming that you're
learning you're digesting as much as
possible I love online marketing and so
I would go and learn everything about
whatever platform I was using most you
know I use YouTube the most right now is
a 37 year old and so I would look at
YouTube as the place where I would want
to learn as much as I could and really
to understand the YouTube algorithm and
to start to win there you could
understand everything you needed to know
about YouTube's algorithm in a day by
consuming lots of other people's content
and looking at the experts and seeing
what they have to say you could no more
than 99% of youtubers in one day you
couldn't do that in another industry
where experiences is super super
important I'm going to be looking at how
can I provide that value to somebody
else how could I approach a youtuber who
I look up to and say listen using a lot
of love you
I love all your content I watch it every
day there's some key things that you're
missing that I'd love to help you with
and provide value on and I would do it
for free at the start once a gain some
experience and credibility and
recognition but also if you're providing
a good service for them and they like it
they're going to want to hire you right
to say go in and help them with a couple
of their videos and it works because
you've done the research and they're
seeing the results you're providing
value what do you get for providing
value you get paid you get money right
and so if you provide an insane value to
a youtuber and their channel is
exploding they're going to want to keep
you onboard now the first person you do
it for they may not want to keep you
onboard even want they may want to steal
your idea and do it all themselves they
may not have seen results in which gives
you didn't do a good job but if you do
that a couple times you're not going to
get ten people all say I'm just going to
steal see what I'm not going to pay you
for your service and so may not work the
first time I may not work the second
time but the third fourth or fifth time
it's going to work eventually you'll
find the people who really value what
you do and once you're in you can build
a long-term relationship with them
you'll get referrals you'll be able to
grow this business out and so I would
focus on YouTube but for you maybe it's
Instagram
maybe it's Facebook maybe you love
Twitter maybe it's musically and finally
the people who you can look at in that
market who are having success but could
be doing way better or helping port
people to a new market you know if
somebody's big on YouTube like me but
isn't doing as much on snapchat maybe
you're the snapchat king maybe you
understand everything about snapchat and
you're on top of every algorithm update
your top of every filter and every
strategy and every idea and you love my
content and is the way you can help me
explode on snapchat and turn a real ROI
on that talk to me let's see how we can
make something happen right that's the
game that you want to start to get into
that's what I would do if I was starting
over right now tip number five is start
small this is one of the hardest things
to do because I remember being 19 years
old and having big ambitions who want to
do big things and then being frustrated
with slow progress and slow results a
lot of people put in so much energy at
the start and then they dig burn out you
know and they never really had a chance
to let their business grow we're
starting a company does take some time
right it's not for lack of effort or
lack of hustle and lack of work it just
doesn't happen the next week or the next
you've got to put in consistent work if
you look at any successful entrepreneur
that you look up to they put in
consistent consistent consistent work so
if you're looking at what do I need to
do to start small and take daily action
that may even mean go get a part-time
job we'll get a job working at now if
you're going to get a job it's not just
to earn money but to learn like if you
want to know YouTube inside out go work
for our youtuber who's having success
that you look up to if you want to learn
digital marketing go work for digital
digital marketing company that has ten
employees or less and take on as much as
you can to really learn that business
you're getting paid to learn the
industry so that may be an option and
start on the side research as much as
possible hustle every day reach out
multiple times to people every single
day and eventually those are going to
turn into wind but you're going to get a
lot of fails a lot of small nose over
and over and over and over again and
most people just quick too soon like
most people you may reach out to ten
people you get ten nose or really you
have to reach out to 500 people you
should not put in enough reps so start
small and understand that with patience
and dedicated action you're going to
grow tip number six is model success one
of the great things about any business
is you can reverse engineer if somebody
has figured out how to do it if somebody
looks like you and has had success you
could do it too a lot of young
entrepreneurs came online because it saw
Mark Zuckerberg and Facebook take off
and they feel this young guy who becomes
a billionaire and gets everybody's
respect so if he can do it I can do it
too and so there's somebody that looks
like you who's on we made it you can
make it too and being surrounded by that
I think is important because young
people more and more and more and more
are getting respect in the business
world because you can provide real value
but you may not feel it from your media
environment your parents might think
you're crazy like what are you doing you
want to be a gamer what are you talking
about you can't make money on video
games like the people around you who are
older who grew up in a different
generation they love you and they're
looking out for you but they may not
understand how today's economy really
really works and so it's hard to stay
dedicated to that thing that you really
want to do when everybody around you is
so negative and so create a better
environment for yourself model and
success models because of what saved my
company I was 19 I wanted to quit I told
my partner right
and looking at Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft gave me a strategy
that I can use for my company and we
started to make money and so that really
helped save my business you could do the
same it's even easier now because
there's people to reach out to people
are doing live hangout people who you
can send an Instagram message to and
they're going to write back to you look
I wish hangouts was a thing when I was
19 I was still going to libraries you
know and studying that libraries and
getting research from books right I mean
books are still great I have my own but
I wish I had the Internet I wish I had
people that I can connect with you know
I do hangouts almost once a week on my
channel you can reach me you can reach
Gary Vaynerchuk you can reach other
business leaders you can reach people on
Twitter you can you can connect with
people and ask real questions and get
feedback on and so I would use that to
my advantage you know being a young
person gives you that advantage where
people want to give back if it seems
genuine if it seems authentic if it
feels like you really want to make this
thing happen
people like giving back because they see
themselves in you they see like if you
write to me anytime sunny write to me is
like hey I'm a 13 year old entrepreneur
I think of myself at 13 like man how
awesome would it be Google to reach out
to somebody who's accomplished more than
me when I was 13 and gets direct
feedback and so doing the work if you're
going to ask for questions though ask
for one question don't ask for a million
questions one question and then do the
work do not come back to that same
person ask another question until you
did the work on the first thing that you
asked for otherwise you're wasting their
time and in tip number seven is create a
great environment and I talked a little
bit about that on the modeling success
but you have people around you who are
discouraging you and you're you're
trying to do one of the most difficult
things in the world which is start a
business it's no joke it's not an easy
overnight things a lot of dedicated work
that has to go into it and if you have
people around you who don't support your
vision it's really hard to get that
going and so I'll be looking at my
environment my physical environment like
where are you working working out of
your bedrooms great what's on the walls
what are you looking at everyday what
inspires you what's your morning routine
every day you need to start your morning
with something that inspires you makes
you feel like you can be an entrepreneur
and have success whether it's watching
one of my videos reading a book watching
somebody else's videos tune into
somebody
like whatever it is whatever the thing
is it gets you feeling confident if I
can go out and do this do that every
single morning because otherwise you're
going to get too discouraged you're
going to have moments of excitement and
I can do anything and then you're going
to fall back down you're not going to
work for a week because your parents are
hating on you or your friends are hating
on you or you teachers say you're never
going to do anything in the
Entrepreneurship world you know so
having that daily consistent action to
make you feel bold confident powerful
entrepreneurial is super important
whatever that thing is it gets you juice
and motivated every single morning start
with it and it can't be the same video
like the same video or the same song
will will phase out you can watch this
video want to be motivated the next day
a little bit more motivated and then
it'll start the right it's going to fall
off so you need a source that's why I
make videos daily because there's always
something new for people to digest and
consume and feel good about themselves
on and learn something from but if it's
an offer you like you know read a
different book of theirs you go through
a couple pages a day or again somebody's
consistent on snapchat it's not about
that one snap six months ago that they
did it's the next one that they do in
the next one to do so having a constant
source of new motivation for you every
single day and starting your day with it
is super important those are my seven
tips on how to make money as a teenage
entrepreneur thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I love to
know which was your favorite tip what
did you enjoy the most
then I miss an 8 9 10 that you want to
add to the list leave it down in the
comments and if you respond and leave in
a comment in the first few hours after
this video went live you have a chance
to win one of our two daily prizes I
made this video because noises valina
asked me to if you want to vote on the
next top seven waves video I should make
check out the link in the description
you can go there give us your
suggestions and maybe you'll get I also
want to give a quick shout out to [ __ ]
awoke thank you so much for picking up a
cup of my book you're one word taking
that picture posting the Instagram I
really appreciate it
I see that my book is on the left side
and so I'm assuming you're reading from
left to right and so that'd be awesome
of the first choice to read on that list
but thank you so much again for sharing
and I really hope you enjoy the read
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love
I'll see you